the biden white house apparently isn't
telling the truth about its efforts to
crack down on crime they claim to be
working with local law enforcement to
help stop the staggering wave of smash
and grab thefts but a top sheriff's
group says that's a bunch of baloney and
that they're unaware of any planned
response by the federal government
meantime as philadelphia sees a record
number of homicides this year the
radical district attorney there is
playing cleanup after making this
outrageous claim
there is not
a big spike in crime that is not true
there is also not a big spike in violent
crime neither one of these things is
true basically
we don't have a crisis of lawlessness we
don't have a crisis of crime we don't
have a crisis of violence
larry krasner now claims he was
inarticulate and is blasting the media
for focusing too much on that comment of
course blame the media we heard what you
said you jackass greg
uh are you calling me a jackass okay no
yeah it is i don't know how anybody can
say that when the the statistics are
staring in front of you when
philadelphia is breaking records and and
murder i don't know how he can do that
the only i think the reason why he's
dismissing crime is that he's culpable
obviously he's a hardcore left ea who's
let out a lot of people who've ended up
hurting other people and he's also like
a lot of people in the media walled off
from crime it's kind of i was thinking
about this you know that if there was a
if we were in
a relatively safe period in a relatively
dangerous period you might never know
the difference never know the difference
because it's not in your neighborhood
and so i think that's what you're seeing
is you're seeing a lot of people
disengaged from real life either behind
a gated community sucking on the teat of
cnn believing that there is no crime or
if there is crime it's done by white
supremacists and then you have the media
who cannot acknowledge a crime wave
because they were embracing the policies
like no cash bail and and emptying jails
which helped cause us so that media
can't government the polit the
politicians can't admit to it because
they're guilty and so all you have left
is this weird state of denial it just
and then it shows you just how absurd it
is when somebody can burn down a tree
and he's back on the street outside out
in front of the building because the
city new york city again one billion
dollars sent to de blasio's wife to deal
with a mentally ill we have a poor
mentally ill man living on the street
he's back there yeah burn down the tree
he's back there because our city won't
do a gd thing for him
sorry see i at least i abbreviated he's
self-sensitive yeah no i i
emailed a psychiatrist i know who works
at bellevue and said why wasn't he
taking a bellevue yeah he's like it's
not he's like i don't know he was like i
can't answer that he was like you should
have been taken to bellevue rather than
sitting across watching the tree
lighting yeah um
jesse i wanted to bring up though that
um there's a fight bruin in uh los
angeles county between alex villanueva
and george gascon out there where george
gascon called he said when you wrestle
with a pig you both get muddy and they
said oh i don't mean law enforcement but
that's good this is a fight between evil
or deeply evil and good yeah i think the
the phrase is uh don't wrestle a pig
you get dirty and the pig likes it
but um yeah i think obviously we all
know what's going on there i'm
interested to know why the democrats
don't want to get the feds involved in
crime because knowing the democrats they
get the feds involved with everything
they want to federalize elections health
care guns obviously the border but for
some reason they don't want federal
involvement with the sheriffs with the
crime thing and then i got to thinking
because i think so much
i got to thinking well what crimes do
the democrats really care about and it
seems to be they only care about the
crimes that get big headlines and that
they can exploit for power they care
about hate crimes they care about covid
crimes they care about police misconduct
they care about january 6th those are
the types of things they're focused on
and then i went to the fbi website i
figured out what's the priority of the
fbi under joe biden administration you
know what the front page of the fbi
website has up right now
encouraging the public to report hate
crimes
seeking information about violence at
the capitol pay attention to holiday
scams pay attention to vaccine scams and
then they have a podcast the fbi has a
podcast podcast on this episode of
inside the fbi we uncover the truth
about some of our noteworthy cases
involving ufos
why are you doing a podcast on ufos when
there's a murder record right now
30-year murder record smash 12 cities
smashing homicide records smash and grab
everywhere and they're focused on
january 6 they're focused on hate crime
hoaxes and holiday scams it's because
they don't care about things that they
can't take advantage of politically
they'll care about black on black crime
if an illegal alien kills someone they
don't care about that that's not a
priority to them their priority is
political crimes that's it that's why
the department of justice started going
after parents at school board meetings
and the department of justice took on
the theft of joe biden's daughter's
diary
because that was an interstate crime
potentially when she possibly left it in
a hotel but that theft was more was
important enough for the doj to take it
on but not record murder rates
it's a lot there let me try
to answer a little bit of it i think the
model for democrats and republicans when
we think about what's happening in our
cities because i think that's where the
key concern is is what we've done here
in new york we elected a mayor who will
take office in a little less than a
month
who is battling publicly with some
forces that want to see him
not re-empower the police to do things
not see them deploy street units to go
out and help in communities all across
the city i think even on one of our
other shows earlier in the day i think
there's some dispute between the mayor
and the leader of the black league
black lives matter movement here in new
york city i hope the mayor prevails
because we need not only more police on
the street but mental health initiatives
here in new york um i can't answer for
the doj and the fbi and all of those
things but what i do know uh is that the
numbers are up the things you don't want
up in crime or up in the things that you
want down or not down that's where the
focus should be mental health
putting more police on the street
reforming bell reform uh and standing up
to those be they democrat or republican
who want to stand in your way if we do
those things this city will be safer and
every american city will be safer greg
talked about this about the danger of
data mining and also to his point the
only line of defense that the left is
coming up with is
well the murder rates are below where
they were in the early 90s and 80s oh
well new york city we have less fewer
than 500 murders this year it was over
2600 back in 1990 i'm like that's your
goal right that's your talking point and
then what's president biden doing
nothing but weak feckless action or
inaction you know his first thing as doj
comes does when coming into office is
we're going to exonerate half of the
portland rioters and then president
trump he said hey you cities who aren't
solving crime in your jurisdictions i'm
going to call you anarchist
jurisdictions we're going to take your
federal funding what does biden do get
rid of the memo biden aided and abetted
the defund the police
movement you hear jen saki tacitly
quietly say we're against defund the
police oh wait but my guy on the
campaign trail was asked do you want to
take funding from the police and he said
absolutely he has aided and abetted
everything we're seeing we talk about
liberal da's and we should we should
also talk about the guy sitting in the
white house who's doing absolutely nil
criminal justice is about justice for
victims
not criminals
straight ahead the white house spin
about the economy getting destroyed by a
record surge in inflation hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else